europe's premier art fair can be a
bewildering place for the uninitiated
and it can sometimes feel like the
artists are taking the mickey but the
experts say demand is strong
it's a very bullish market uh in the in
the art market right now and even though
the the stock market is fairly quiet and
actually slightly sluggish uh the our
market is extremely strong
here we are at thomas gaines gallery one
of the really top galleries in london
he's really built up the careers of a
number of superb artists and we're going
to see one one example of one of the top
artists that has really skyrocketed both
in importance and appreciation and this
is hervin anderson a lot of people are
saying this is the next
artist that could make
huge amounts of money
surrealist belgian artist carsten holler
is not one of hoffman's top picks it's
not an artist that we would look at as
an investment it you know may well
appear in a museum collectors might have
it in a garden but we wouldn't invest in
it we don't see it as you know being the
top lot of christians or zombies um
maybe i'll be proved completely wrong
and then we'll look back in 20 years but
actually it's not where we'll be putting
our money uh right now hoffman's final
pick two well-known names in british art
circles damien hirst and anthony gormley
right now this is the one of the top
lots um or top works being sold at
freeze estimated around four million
pounds it's an early work there's now a
real resurgence in interest in early
works and here's an example of
some markets where it goes down and then
comes bouncing back just like other
markets in the contemporary world like
crystal wool you'd see that you see it
goes down maybe 50 then goes up by four
times with the global art market topping
the 47 billion euro level savvy
investors could paint themselves a
pretty profit tom mckenzie bloomberg